[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Francis costard
directeur programme amateur de la Merise
à Trappes bonjour bonjour Alors du 6 au
12 mars vous organisez le festival show
meuf Gohan une semaine qui n'est pas
choisie au hasard puisqu'elle fait
référence au 8 mars donc la journée de
lutte pour les droits des femmes quel
est l'objectif de cet événement donc on
travaille depuis des années sur la ville
de trappes à la mise en avant voilà des
femmes
dans leurs différents rôles au quotidien
dans leur vie professionnelle mais voilà
c'est vraiment pris à cœur tellement à
coeur qu'on a même une élue dédiée à ça
Muriel Bernard pour par la cité voilà
qui est en charge voilà de
la vie inclusive et de l'égalité femme
homme j'ai pris une note des notes pour
donc
dédié à ça et donc on travaille avec
elle tout au long de l'année justement
sur sur ça et on voulait un moment un
autre mettre vraiment l'accent et le
phare sur sur une semaine dédiée dans la
culture
aux femmes voilà où elles sont mises en
avant donc dans les différents types
d'art vivants et on vous allez voir tout
le long de la semaine nous avons des
performances voilà maintenues par les
femmes faites par les femmes et que ça
soit à la fois dans le théâtre mais dans
la musique et puis mais également
aussi dans la danse donc presque d'une
volonté politique finalement de la ville
vous avez voulu justement mettre en
avant ces femmes donc rejoindre
finalement cette cette valorisation
voulue par la ville de Trappes comme
toute l'année on travaille dessus on a
des mardi le 1er mardi de chaque mois en
thématique ça ne peut pas être spécial
justement vers versa on voulait un
moment à l'autre vraiment mettre
l'accent dessus et sur une semaine
dédiée à ça voilà alors donc ça
s'appelle le chôme of Gohan donc c'est
la semaine du 8 mars du coup autour du 8
mars pourquoi la Meurice a justement
décidé non pardon ça c'était la question
de d'avant c'est la marraine du festival
pardon des autres que l'humoriste
Caroline Vigneau qui se produira
également pour pour cette semaine on va
justement parler de la programmation
donc le festival est organisé par la mer
et la ville de Trappes c'est la première
édition de ce festival c'est donc une
volonté de la part de la ville mais
aussi de de la vôtre d'organiser un
événement qui met en avant les femmes
les spectacles se feront à l'auditorium
du conservatoire ou à la Meurice alors
qu'est-ce qui est prévu justement pour
le 6 mars jour du lancement du festival
normalement l'entité meurise et la ville
ne peut pas dissocier puisque la mûrise
dépend de la ville donc voilà donc
c'était une volonté de la ville surtout
une de nos élus et donc nous voilà en
tant que technicien on a réfléchi à ça
on a proposé ça donc la volonté de
mettre ça en place voilà comme je disais
c'est c'est de de mettre vraiment
l'accent sur les femmes à ce moment-là
et alors pourquoi Caroline Vigneaux pour
la simple raison c'est que bah ça fait
des années qu'elle défend les femmes et
puis avec humour voilà même si des fois
ça peut paraître léger c'est pas si
léger que ça il y a un vrai combat
derrière et une vraie discussion elle a
même fait un film voilà flashback qui
sera en ouverture du festival donc le
lundi on a réussi à avoir les droit
auprès de Amazon et donc ça va être
distribué les gens pourront venir
gratuitement voilà et Caroline Vignaud
en plus sera là pour ouverture donc elle
sera là pour l'ouverture de film et
expliquer dans quelles conditions et
pourquoi elle a fait ce film et puis
elle clôturera le festival donc le
dimanche suivant d'après et alors le 7
mars c'est la compagnie Le Grand Chelem
qui portera son spectacle libre arbitre
mis en scène par Julie Bertin et Léa
Girardet que va raconter la pièce je
sais pas si vous en souvenez
[Musique]
aux Jeux olympiques de 2009 à Berlin il
y a une femme
castersenia qui a gagné remporté le 800
mètres elle a remporté la médaille d'or
et elle s'est vu retirer sa médaille
puisque elle avait un taux d'hormones
supérieur à celui des femmes et donc on
lui a demandé soif c'est un traitement
soit on lui remettait pas sa médaille
elle pouvait pas la garder donc elle a
refusé bien sûr faire ce traitement
puisque pour aller à les femmes et voilà
ça traite de ce sujet là de ce combat de
cette femme qui essaie de récupérer sa
médaille d'or sans pour autant
changer
le jeudi 9 mars c'est le spectacle
jamais je n'oublie que les Yvelines
pourront découvrir qu'est-ce qui attend
le public c'est la compagnie bitter
sweet qui présente ça
par un internat de sa chorégraphe donc
perle qui est rond qui qui est des
Yvelines quoi elle est de joueurs
Pontchartrain et
la thématique est un peu particulière
donc c'est sur la mémoire sur l'oubli
c'est un travail donc c'est un triptyque
et ça travaille sur ces maladies
d'Alzheimer donc
voilà ça avait sa place parce que bon
bah c'est une femme du territoire perle
et donc c'est un couple il y a un garçon
aussi qui qui danse avec eux et
j'aurais là-dessus en parlant du
jugement du garçon c'est que
l'intérêt c'est que voilà on met en
avant une femme chorégraphe du
territoire alors je rebondis sur le côté
masculin parce que quand j'ai contacté
Caroline de Vigneaux au départ quand
même à refusé tout net parce que je lui
ai mis c'est un échangeait par mail un
festival 100% féminin et m'a dit il est
hors de question que je participe à un
festival 100% féminin ou 100% masculin
je lui ai dit non non il y a des hommes
et des femmes dedans voilà mais c'est la
mise en avant et c'est le travail toute
l'année ce que j'expliquais tout à
l'heure et je lui dis on s'en doute que
les garçons qui sont à la fois avec les
sorbertholet en musiciens ou le garçon
qui dansait j'ai pas les coller une
perruque pour dire que c'est 100%
féminin et donc de l'as dit c'est bon
j'accepte alors on retourne au théâtre
avec le spectacle tu seras un homme ma
fille le vendredi 10 mars alors un
spectacle qui tourne autour justement de
l'identité des genres la condition
féminine et la place des femmes dans la
société pourquoi c'était une évidence
justement de présenter ce spectacle dans
le cadre du festival show meuf Gohan on
parle de tout ce qui est non on parle du
statut de la femme et puis voilà donc
c'était évident pour nous de mettre
justement l'accent là-dessus puisque
qu'est-ce que c'est que ton genre et
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être une femme
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un être un homme
voilà on est en 2023 quelle est la place
de chacun à la fois alors ça traite de
sujet pas uniquement en France mais
également aussi un étranger la place des
femmes dans certaines castes voilà on a
un notamment et le rôle de de des femmes
dans chaque peu partout au travers des
civilisations et et des âges voilà et
encore une fois voilà vous l'avez évoqué
c'est pas 100% 100% féminin mais c'est
surtout la valorisation des artistes
féminines des auteurs féministes fa
féminines pardon des auteurs féminines
des des actrices féminines etc c'est une
valorisation ces deux femmes
Jessica pour pas la cité qui qui elle
travaille depuis longtemps avec nous à
la Meurice elle intervient même en au
niveau des scolaires et donc bah voilà
c'est elle qui a écrit
cette pièce de théâtre et donc on
voulait aussi voilà avoir quelque chose
qui mène du territoire mais en même
temps à quelqu'un à qui on a l'habitude
de travailler et bon elle avait notre
confiance et puis voilà et le 11 mars
c'est Camille et Julie Berthollet qui
seront en concert pouvez-vous nous
présenter rapidement ces deux artistes
Camille et Julie ce sont à la fois une
violence et de violoncelle
donc elles ont découvert ça très jeune à
trois ou quatre ans et puis voilà il y a
énormément qui est derrière et puis
c'est devenu tout seul c'est devenu
carrément une passion et toute la
famille vit au rythme des filles et
voilà elles se sont fait connaître et
remarquer ce qui est intéressant chez
ces filles-là c'est qu'elles amènent la
justement la musique classique la
détourne pour l'amener plus important à
tout le monde et puis on peut l'aborder
et la voir d'un prisme différent ce qui
est intéressant
avec elle c'est que là par exemple c'est
series ça c'est le dernier album toutes
les musiques que vous avez pu entendre
que ça soit mission impossible ou que ça
soit également
là on a on a bella ciao par exemple je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait juste
après ça parle de
[Musique]
Camille et Julie Bertholet donc ça c'est
le 11 mars à la Meuse Caroline Vigneaux
du coup fermera le festival le 12 mars
avec avec son spectacle est-ce que votre
souhait justement c'est que show meuf
Gohan continue l'année prochaine donc
soit renouvelé l'année prochaine et au
fil des années je vous parle là à peu
près 90% de ma programmation pour la
saison 23 24 est déjà pratiquement
bouclée et donc oui il y a une deuxième
édition du festival show meuf Gohan
voilà et ben alors si on loupe quelques
dates on pourra regarder la
programmation pour pour l'année
prochaine à peu près au même date de
toute façon
la mise en avant des femmes que ce soit
voilà dans le théâtre dans le jeune
public voilà on a eu été découvrir une
artiste là l'année prochaine espagnol
voilà qu'on m'a ramener et donc ça sera
l'occasion également le 6 mars d'avoir
un événement gratuit et de découvrir
notamment une artiste du territoire
merci beaucoup Francis costard d'avoir
été avec nous sur sensation donc je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur
programmateur de la maryse ATRAP pour
plus d'informations on peut se rendre
sur le site trap mag.fr et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]